Kaitlyn Kaitlyn Caitlyn Caitlyn I'm off
the grid for August but fear not CNN is
still a far-left activist organization
pretending to be a journalistic outfit
speaking of another comment that you've
made that is getting attention today
about 911 a report in the Atlantic that
you gave an interview to you said quote
I think it is legitimate to say how many
police how many federal agents were on
the planes that hit the Twin Towers
maybe the answer is zero it probably is
zero for all I know right I have no
reason to think it was anything other
than zero but if we're doing a
comprehensive assessment of what
happened on 911 we have a 911 Commission
absolutely there should be an answer the
public knows the answer to explain to me
what you meant
there this is really it's funny I mean
the Atlantic is playing the same game as
CNN it's funny what I said is on January
6th I do believe that there were many
federal agents in the field and we
deserve to know who they are on 911 what
I've said is that the government lied
and this is incontrovertible evidence
Caitlyn the government government lied
about Saudi Arabia's involvement there
was a Saudi spy named albumi who they
lied and the government lied and the 911
Commission lied we know that because
Declassified reports in 2021 revealed
that Al was indeed what's that yeah the
report that the President Biden
Declassified but your quote here are you
telling me that the quote is wrong ler
but are you telling me that your quote
is wrong here because it says how many
federal agents were on the plane Towers
yeah when I when I actually and this is
just lifting the curtain on how media
works again I asked that reporter to
send the recording cuz it was on the
record he refused to do it but we had a
free flowing conversation the truth is
there are lies the government has told
about 911 but it's not the ones that
somebody put in my mouth it's the one
that I articulated which is that Saudi
Arabia absolutely their intelligence was
involved in 911 and our government for
20 years lied to the American people
about it there was an entire 911 report
on this yes and it and it lied and it
was false and in fact you know where
that's coming out Caitlyn there's now a
case a federal case in the southern
district of New York where the
government of Saudi Arabia is being sued
by victims of families that's why this
is resurfacing itself it is relevant and
it turns out a difference in questions
about Saudi Arabia's involvement and the
government's involvement and then
pushing this idea that whenever what
your comment about who was on the plane
and then was 911 an inside job where you
did not say no earlier that's why it's
important to clarify those comments
because otherwise it feels like you're
towing at the line when it comes to
conspiracy theories Caitlyn I it is I I
I am guilty as charged that I do not
follow the establishment superpac donor
approved script on these questions but I
am speaking truth grounded in fact at
every step of the way and that's what's
really elicited something of an
anaphylactic reaction of the kind we saw
in 2016 against a different candidate
guess what we'll put a gun in every
Taiwanese household train them how to
use it that is how you make Xi Jinping
think
twice do you really think that would be
a sufficient plan to deter a Chinese inv
if it includes long range missiles
ground troops an aerial blockade a naval
blockade all different measures Caitlyn
Kaitlyn of course it's not sufficient
you take that chiny little clip when
I've articulated at the Nixon Library
last week a one-hour speech with a whole
range of deterrents that is part of it
but I've also said that I would pull
Russia out of its military alliance with
China I've also said that we would
bolster our partnership with India to be
able to close the SE and the Mala
straight I've also said that we would
actually send a signal very clearly that
we will defend Taiwan moving from
strategic ambiguity to strategic Clarity
to say that we will defend Taiwan until
we have semiconductor Independence in
this country and so yes part of this is
turning Taiwan into a porcupine I think
exporting our Second Amendment is a
relatively free or lowcost way to do
that but I find it laughable that you
will take that clip and then put words
into my mouth as though that was a
sufficient Det deterrent Caitlyn with
due respect that's a joke especially
when I've offered expansive of a
deterrent strategy it's not putting
words into your mouth and it's not
saying that you didn't say those other
things it's just saying that you did say
that part of
your never said it was sufficient people
in Taiwan
handguns this is really funny Kay it
just is it's been very educational for
me to learn how media Works yes that is
important that no one ever said that was
sufficient to deter an
invasion